you married your wife in 2 and 1/2
months I I was 23 when we got engaged
and she was 20 how do you know when the
person that you're seeing is the right
person you can determine if it's the
wrong person in the first 10 minutes
that's actually real easy the right
person you have to be sexually attracted
to the person obviously you have to find
them fun to be with but people tend to
think of those as like the only
conditions and then there's the actual
conditions for marriage which is you're
signing onto a lifelong commitment here
which is going to be much harder than
you could possibly imagine because
you're going to have presumably kids and
they're an enormous commitment and
you're going to have hardships and
you're going to have tragedies and
you're going to have you know
difficulties and they're going to crop
up not like some days they're going to
crop up most days there will be
something bad that happens on almost
every day of your life the nice thing
about getting married young is that
you're able to sort of shape each other
a little bit which is nice when you get
married older everybody's got their
baggage everybody's got their
established modes of life and it's kind
of harder to make those mesh but the
things that we did share were the
unshakable things